the one thing I always remember thinking
initially when I was trying to make
films and he always felt like you got
nervous that somebody else was right who
was talking to you know who maybe was in
a position of power like that their
opinion somehow was was right or better
than yours and somehow and he could
never stop to think like no it's just
different you just think differently
than I do and that's okay you know but
I'm not wrong you seeing it can get
filled with such fear and it's really
easy to get to just get your heart
broken and kind of sort of beaten you're
sort of attempting to make films I mean
you just it's a miracle anytime any one
of them gets made you know it's a
miracle and it's a miracle every time I
feel like it's a miracle every time a
scene kind of gets done and through the
birth canal and done I mean it's never
any less of a miracle or any less
difficult
just a kind of it just should be no fear
you know I think that's just always
remember kind of being pummeled by fear
early on and feeling like God if I could
have just got rid of that fear earlier
this might have been a little bit easier
I just don't give a that's kind of
the best thing to do